going baseline is waiters he'll come
back out the other side
as curly neal impersonation all that
dribbling over wagner for two
so waders has his first bucket of the
afternoon oh cheese now not philly
cheese if you're gonna go
nicknames uh jared dudley told that to
michael
trudell the other day j r swish from d
at the walt disney world wide world of
sports
been there it's a great facility jr's
got it again
down it goes yes sir super bouncy looks
like in great health and great form and
laker fans everywhere i i
look after they lost the first scrimmage
as they knocked down another three
wherever you may be across the country
here is uh waiters he's going to try and
he's going to go in and score
both these teams are shooting at their
50 percent score on the restart roster
i think he might be japan's greatest
basketball player already even though
he's only going to a second j
r smith yes sir from the outside he's
still hot
hot as he is right now doubled up at the
rim that's good rim protection by the
lakers here they come
with it is waiters waiters all the way
left hand but the early shack
the check was when shaq joined the
lakers in 2000 2001 when he was just
destroying the league
everybody's getting out of his way
that's the most impressive imposing
physical specimen i've ever seen play
this game
and uh dwyane wade and chris bosh in
miami but still he has been the vocal
guy the main guy that's a lot of
responsibility right quarter three from
alex caruso they can't be there for now
you still
get to play the game you love you get a
chance to get a championship and you
like you say you know fans are
changing r smith gohan
got it again this fast shot from j.r
smith he has a sort of double clutching
here knew the balls guys behind him had
a chance to block it he's still
concentrating knocked it down
look at that stride strutting around
like he's rip flare
i like that
has another bucket if you joined us very
late
a lot of laker players didn't play
tonight waiters
that's it from three troy brown turns 21
tomorrow for this washington team dion
going to the bucket hard
waiters was determined to get the shot
off but they sent a double team out of
it but he said he's not going to let
that deny him he's going to find a way
to get his shot
somewhere